hi we're here to talk to you about how
we are rethinking AB distribution on
Google Play we'll talk about the new app
publishing format the Android a bundle
which we've launched at i/o this year
and all the features we've built since
kind of in in this area but to start
with let's talk about the app size why
does the app size even matter so you all
know that app size is important we
shared with you this chart earlier this
year at Google i/o according to play
store data as app size gets bigger their
install success rate goes down users
don't have enough storage especially in
emerging markets where the connections
are slow the data is expensive and I
want you to think about your own
experience too how many of you have seen
this message by Google Play asking you
to uninstall apps to make space for more
installs millions of users see that
everyday we started to look into this
more closely recently and we found out
that clearing up space is a major driver
of an installs and this is obviously a
problem for entry-level devices and
emerging markets but it's also a problem
for users who fill up their devices with
HD content take the US and the UK for
example one in five users are getting to
the point that they run out of space in
which they can't really install or
update anymore a key request we've heard
from developers is also for help
understanding and reducing uninstalls we
ran a user research study where with our
users in the US about the reasons why
they uninstall apps and what we've heard
as the leading reasons why users
uninstall within the first day is
quality quality something we do care a
lot and as Thomson has said we have a
separate Android vital session later
where we can tell you all about how to
improve the performance of your app
however the leading reasons why users
uninstall the apps after it's been on
the device for a month is to save up
space
so what this shows you is there are two
big reasons why you should care about
the size of your app bigger apps lose
acquisitions and bigger apps also get
uninstalled more often I think many of
you are kind of already aware of this so
you would think that everyone would be
doing everything in their power to
reduce the size of their app and yet
apps and games keep getting bigger over
the last five years the size of the app
has effectively went five times it's
five times larger on average newer
devices have more storage but apps and
games and HD videos and you know
high-res photos all those things are
getting larger too now there are also
some very good reasons why the apps are
getting bigger
Koby tell us more about it so the first
reason is that you simply keep add
adding awesome features and services to
your app and you come up with new ideas
and you take advantage of device
capabilities but with every new feature
you obviously increase the app size and
you know Android has this amazing
diversity diversity there are thousands
of devices to choose from and you want
your apps and games to run beautifully
on all those devices so many developers
add all those resources in their apks to
support architectures and screen
densities and languages and when you add
all these resources you increase the
size of your app so we've seen two main
reasons why apps keep getting bigger you
add awesome features and you add
resources to support all the Android
devices out there but we've also seen
that increasing the app size comes with
downsides and I'm sure some of you have
considered the following trade-off
before do I keep on adding features and
resources or my app runs really well on
all those devices but I lose installs
and drive more uninstalls along the way
this is a pretty bad trade-off we don't
want you to be making those kind of
trade-offs
so there is a current way to optimize
your app for different device
configurations we call it multiple apks
but it's kind of inefficient and frankly
we think it can be quite tedious this is
what it looks like in the play console
when you have to upload dozens of apks
for each of your releases the number of
apks can grow quite quickly with
different dimensions for example 64-bit
versus 32-bit smaller screens larger
screens and so on and then on top of
that you have to version each apk
individually which kind of adds to the
to the complexity about this it also
doesn't help with all of the dimensions
for example for languages you still need
to include all languages in each one of
your apks so multi apk is you know kind
of not a solution it's not great we know
we can do better let's look at the
actual solution we've built for this and
how the new app model helps make your
life easier in this area new app model
is focused on improving the entire user
acquisition journey from discovery
through to retention it helps by making
your app smaller and as such kind of
improving both your install and
uninstall rate and in addition to that
it makes managing your release as much
easier in this session we're going to
talk about four steps in the user
acquisition journey we want to help you
with first we want to help you with
discovery by allowing users to try your
apps then we want to help you convert
users to installers next we want to
allow you to deliver features and
functionality on demand to different
audiences when they need it and finally
we want to help you retain your users
with the latest and greatest version of
your app we're going to start by how we
help you make your installs smaller this
is the first step in your journey as a
developer and
where we made a big announcement at
Google i/o with the Android app bundle
we're going to talk about the other
steps in the user acquisition journey
later in this talk so here's the big
idea Google Play can assist and take
care of delivering only what is needed
to each device on your behalf
there is no need to send a bunch of free
sources or blank wishes to users devices
if they're not gonna need them
we support three slicing dimensions out
of the box CPU architectures languages
and screen densities to take advantage
of this start building with the new
publishing format the Android app bundle
the size reduction varies but on average
we're seeing 35% size savings compared
to Universal apk this is huge so with
the bundle you get resource slicing for
free and you're also on the road to
using dynamic features and offering
instant experiences both of which we'll
talk about later and we've been chatting
a lot to developers like you about what
is the thing they like about the the
bundle most recently we did a workshop
with some developers in India who make
some sound most popular apps over there
RIA fee red bus and swiggy these
developers have millions of installs and
they're very sophisticated in keeping
the size of their app small because
their users are very sensitive to it
really found that smaller installs
improved their conversion rate Red Bus
founded for releases were streamlined
and much easier to manage and swiggy
found that switching was a simple
process and they were able to start
testing with a bundle within an hour and
it's not just developers in India as you
can see here developers all around the
world are switching and are seeing
fantastic site savings for example
duolingo so 50% 50% site savings
compared to Universal apk
this huge savings is very difficult to
achieve with only incremental
optimization so switching to the app
bundle is the single most impactful
thing developers can do to reduce the
size of their app and Google apps are
switching as well YouTube Google Maps
and Google News are all today in
production with Android app bundles so
as you can see this is not experimental
this is ready we have thousands of our
bundles in production today it's time
for all developers to switch to the new
publishing format as a matter of fact
we've just crossed 10,000 overnight
tonight yesterday um in Android studio 3
- which is now stable and available to
all developers you can build bundles
it's very similar to building an apk so
the switch is pretty straightforward for
most developers and in the Play console
we're starting to show you this very
colorful chart when we think you could
benefit from moving to the bundle we'll
take a common reference device and we'll
calculate how much you save comparing to
a universal apk and we're excited to
share that games using unity can now
start building the bundle to unity added
support for our bundles in the 2018 3
beta release and you can join this beta
right now ok so I think many of you have
heard about all this already but let me
explain how it actually works the way it
works is you put everything related to
your app in the bundle play process as
the bundle and generates these optimized
apks we sign the apks and deliver each
side apk - to each individual user
device this means that the new app model
requires you to to upload your signing
key to Google Play and again in
conversations I've had with developers
it'll like yourself sometimes I've heard
the question of like is this secure and
the app the answer is
lutely rest assured that we take this
very very seriously
we protect your keys in the same storage
and we protect Google's own signing keys
we have a large team of engineers
focused entirely on security and you
will benefit from our ongoing
investments in this area and the reason
this step is so critical is because when
we have the signing key we can optimize
the app that we deliver to devices on an
ongoing basis without your continuous
work and improvements Koby do you want
to share one of those examples sure
so because Google Play does the
processing we can introduce those kind
of optimizations without asking you to
put any time and effort so we just
launched a new optimization for
developers who upload up bundles for an
Android OS feature that was introduced
in Android M called uncompressed native
libraries you know before Android M you
need to provide native libraries
compressed and the OS uncompressed them
so it installs two copies on the device
after Android M you can provide your
native libraries uncompressed and the OS
only installs a single copy saving a lot
of space now because Google Play does
the processing we can do it for you but
if if we haven't you actually need to
fork your app for pre em and post them
with multi apk which is pretty painful
and who would want to do that right so
we're doing it for you if you're using
the app bundle you just give us your
native libraries compressed or
uncompressed we create the different
flavors for pre M and post them saving
users a lot of space on the device the
numbers you see here for example are for
Gameloft's game My Little Pony these
numbers are on top of the numbers they
actually got from switching to the
bundle in the first place the numbers
resync on average across the entire app
corpus are still very significant 8%
reduction in the download size on
average and 16% reduction in size on
disk on
average so with this optimization the
download is smaller the install is
faster and it takes less space on this
and this is exactly the kind of
optimizations we can introduce on your
behalf without asking you to put any
time or effort and I guess some of you
might be thinking well if we provide
Google Play our libraries uncompressed
it might increase the size of the
artifact we upload to Google and some of
you might be worried that it may push
your limit over the hundred megabyte
upload limit we have in the play console
so the good news is that we're actually
changing all the size logic in the play
console to be based on the compressed
download size you know the upload size
isn't really meaningful especially not
in a world of mock-up bundles it is not
what the user downloads and it not what
ends on their device so starting today
all the size validations in the play
console are based on the compressed
download size and there is one more
change we're making to the app size
limits we were very keen to make life
easier even for developers of large apps
who rely on expansion files today so I'm
happy to announce we are increasing the
download size for apk is generated from
the bundle from 100 megabytes to 500
megabytes this means that for apps up to
500 megabytes you can stop using
expansion files entirely this doesn't
change the size warning on the Play
Store but it does mean that releasing
large app is much easier to manage adobe
has been testing larger bundles with us
with their new video editing app adobe
premiere rush this premium video editing
software is coming soon to Android and
Chromebooks Adobe premium rush uses a
lot of native code so this means that
for them bundle saves them quite a lot
of disk space on each individual user
device we are inviting early access
partners to start testing this with
so if you're interested please reach out
to your BD manager okay so to recap that
was the latest for the Android app
bundle and how we are making your apps
smaller and your release is simpler the
next big change that the new app model
introduces is modularization and dynamic
code loading this is an approved safe
way to load functionality and features
dynamically making your App Store
smaller at install time let me tell you
how this works
dynamic features are conceptually simple
similar to all the other things we do
for our bundles you don't need to send
the same features 200 percent of your
users if you know that only maybe about
10 percent of them will be using it
however there is one big difference
between kind of dynamic feature modular
ization and resource module ization and
that is that feature modulation doesn't
happen among predefined binary is
basically you are in full control around
how you slice out your app and what are
the things you want to deliver
dynamically dynamic features can be
installed on demand when users request
them or you can choose to defer the
installation to a later time for example
when app goes to the to the background
on pre L devices that don't support
dynamic features we fuse all these
optionals in to the main app so it's
delivered at the install time all of
these use cases that have just very
briefly went through our currently
supported introduction by some of the
largest apps on the platform and
millions of users have been benefiting
from them already
Facebook was one of our launch partners
for this functionality and currently
they're using dynamic features in
production across their entire app
portfolio let's take a look at their
story so app size is really important to
Facebook when launching new features
they evaluate the features benefit with
the size it actually adds to the app
dynamic features allow them to add
functionality to apps like Facebook and
Facebook lite
without increasing the size of the app
that install time dynamic features are
also important to their high end device
strategy because they can ship specific
advanced features only to support the
devices they can also remove features
over time to save space or the feature
don't stay for the lifetime of the app
Facebook told us the dynamic features
work especially well for new features
that are separate logically separate
from from the main app they can have a
separate team of engineers work on that
feature and they can then add them to
the app without impacting its base
install size here are some cool examples
of features that are used today in
production by Facebook apps one example
for example is card scanning card
scanning is a functionality that is only
used by a small percentage of Facebook
user base so by turning this into a
dynamic features they avoid shipping
almost two megabyte to every user device
another example is real-time
communication by moving voice and video
chat to a dynamic feature they can make
sure these features are only shipped to
devices that support them and only two
users are interested in using those
features so this is about dynamic
features they make it possible for you
to build highly configurable apps and as
we've seen used in production by some of
the biggest developers on on the
platform now let's talk about another
type of module the Android are bundle
support instant app modules so the next
section is all about the first step in
the user acquisition journey and how we
help you with discovery by helping users
Schreyer apps we've been working on
instant apps over the past two years and
improving it based on your feedback we
recently made URLs optional and we've
added try now flow on the Play Store
Google Play Instant is now on 1.3
billion devices and it
highly compelling historically it used
to be non-trivial effort for developers
to adopt this because of the independent
build and release process now you don't
have to worry about building and
maintaining your instant apps separately
from your installed app as of recently
the Android app bundle supports instant
apps and makes adoption much easier in
Android studio 3.2 you can build an
instant app with the app bundle format
this lets you benefit from all the
bundle size optimizations which means
that you can get under the instant app
limits much easier the requirements
general are pretty simple your instant
app module in your main app entry point
module need to be under ten megabytes to
enable the try Now button in the Play
Store and you need to handle permissions
gracefully like all apps should anyway
but that's not all it's going to become
even easier in Android studio three
three beta version you can now build and
upload a single artifact for your
instant and installed app we let you
upload an artifact of any size to the
play console and then you can start
reducing the size of the artifact to
meet the 10 megabyte limit as we've seen
earlier using dynamic features is the
key strategy in reducing the size of
your app this makes it possible for many
many more of you to start offering
instant experiences for your installed
apps and developers going down this road
are seeing great success because by
offering a trial you can capture many
users who would have otherwise moved on
without installing your app
ultimate guitar you see here told us
that once they launch their instant app
they've seen eight percent increase in
their install size and the twenty
percent of users who click try now ended
up installing the app so this is about
how we allow you to now offer instant
experiences using the Android app bundle
now let's talk about the final
step in user acquisition journey
retaining users over time and one of the
ways you do that is by making sure users
use your latest and greatest app version
and you know that Google Play offers
auto-updates functionality and many many
users have auto update turned on but not
all users and in some markets even
though users have auto updates turned on
they never actually connect to Wi-Fi so
they don't get to update their apps I'm
very happy to announce that today we're
launching a new API that allows you to
prompt users to update without ever
leaving your app you can call this API
to determine if there is an update
available and if so you can show prompt
to users asking asking them to accept
the update in this example flow is
designed for immediate critical use
cases like privacy or revenue affecting
bugs it's a full screen experience where
the user is expected to wait until the
download is complete so that they can
kind of take and start using the new
experience we make this quite easy for
you to adopt because we take care of all
the updating of the app and the entire
lifecycle related to that I think some
of you have already built flows similar
to this but this is now a standardized
method which can be adopted very very
easily
however instead of an immediate update
you can also do a flexible update with
this API which doesn't have to be
applied straightaway this is actually my
favorite part about this API you can
completely customize the update
experience so that it really feels like
something that's part of your app for
example you may decide to very gently
nudge users with an inline flow like
Google Chrome is doing in this example
and once the user accepts the the update
the download starts in the background so
users can keep using your app while the
download is is being fetched once the
download is complete it's basically up
to you to decide when you want to apply
it you can do that straight away and ask
you sir - - to restart the app you can
wait for the app to go back
the background or or for users do to
stop using it
Google Chrome is testing this now we are
inviting all of you to join a sista in
testing this again reach out your bidi
manager if you would like to join us
okay so to recap ensuring more users use
your latest release is important you can
do that by following some of these best
practices here or by integrating with
our in-app updates
API the API is available for any app so
you can get started with it even while
you're in the process of switching to
the Android app bundle so all the
efforts we showed you today are all
about helping you drive more installs
and fewer annastolz offer highly
configurable apps through dynamic
features and keep your users up to date
if you want to come and chat to us we'll
be around with a few folks from our
product and engineering teams if you
want to share anything you've heard
about today this link to the medium post
is a great place to start
thank you for listening and enjoy
playtime thank you
[Applause]